good evening and happy happy Monday oh
my favorite day of the week so on Friday
night we had an amazing show one of the
best shows ever but it got preempted for
coverage of the house Speaker vote
because you know this is a news station
but it was such a great episode that we
knew that you will love and we didn't
want you our amazing fans to miss it we
decided we're airing it now I like to
call this the reverse kill Mead
all right
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy Friday everybody I love Fridays I
love Fridays because right now we
welcome tonight's guests doctors
recommend his act as a general
anesthetic
westernrazor.com owner yes that's right
all our comedians yeah have part-time
jobs yes David Angela
foreign
his parents are in the audience and I
feel terrible for them co-host of fox
and friends first Todd Pyro
she's perfected her smirk when I'm being
a jerk Fox News contributor captive
and finally he's never bit off more than
he could chew my massive decide to get
the NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyra
thank you
all right what a week huh before we get
to some news stories it's Friday so you
know what it's time for
Greg's leftovers
right uh leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's the first time for me to be
reading them so if they suck it's not on
me but I will fire someone because I
like doing that so here we go earlier
this week President Biden said he plans
to visit the southern border for the
first time but only because Hunter is
running low on Fentanyl
oh
I should have used that one yeah
a popular adult star who is now a data
scientist claims she had more sex than
she did have showers in 2022
quote and I've never had either said Sam
bankman free
why are the reject jokes getting better
laughs in the world
Canadian company just introduced a new
self-driving baby stroller it's the
perfect solution for busy moms who are
trying to juggle a family and a drinking
problem
it is pretty awesome
I would do that a suspect in the New
Year's Eve machete attack on three New
York City police officers was reportedly
carrying a diary in which he expressed
his desire to join the Taliban but a
Taliban spokesperson says quote we would
never accept him because Diaries are gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
such homophobia
it's so funny I tried to keep a diary
scientists in China claim they've been
developing a bionic penis
that could eventually cure erectile
dysfunction the only downside you can't
get it wet
[Laughter]
[Applause]
an environmental company is now offering
reusable toilet paper as a way to save
trees the inventor said he got the idea
while on the toilet
and realized he'd run out of pages of
Jesse Waters book
[Applause]
yeah I hope he sees I hope he sees that
outraged Tick-Tock users say yoga videos
have become highly sexualized with some
clips looking more like porn than
exercise videos quote I haven't seen
evidence of a problem yet but I'll keep
watching to make sure
promised this man
[Applause]
[Music]
your parents wrote that joke
[Applause]
this Sunday is the 21st annual no pants
subway ride in New York City which I
love because when panhandlers ask me for
change I don't have to Pat myself down
and pretend not to find any
all right finally I love that word
Hillary Clinton is joining Columbia
University as a global Affairs professor
to show his support bill has already
started interviewing teachers assistance
[Laughter]
all right now let's do a news story CNN
shows they're down with the Tears of a
Clown yes it's time for
Greg's new stelter
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah former Illinois congressman Adam
kinzinger has joined CNN as a senior
political commentator shocking no one
improving their network is still intent
on making people vomit he made his Prime
Time debut this week at the failing
Network which is a rating cycle away
from becoming Trevor Noah foreign
here's the snippet
Congressman we really are thrilled to
have you on board so welcome uh welcome
people have seen you over the past of
course couple years of the January 6
committee it's great to be on the team
by the way thank you I'm excited he is
welcome aboard it's CNN it's like taking
a Lifeboat to the Titanic
supposed to leave not return but I guess
Congress was just a stepping stone to
CNN if things go well it's on to selling
time shares
and remember all the times he was Nancy
Pelosi's sock puppet at the Jan sixth
earrings you can tell she didn't warm
her hands before entering his eyebrows
were higher than hers
we'd be remiss if we didn't play some of
zinger's greatest hits roll it Henrietta
I never expected a day to be quite as
emotional for me as it has been
but you guys won
you guys help
you know democracies are not defined
by our bad days
we're defined by how we come back from
bad days and we thank you for holding
that line
oh my God
don't worry Adam if we were you we'd cry
too and you know it's only a matter of
time before Adam's former colleagues get
new TV gigs too Rumor Has It Liz Chaney
has joined the Food Network
[Laughter]
thank you
she's the uh gonna be the person who
licks the cake batter off the electric
beater
turn it off first
David how you doing
fantastic excellent excellent uh care to
comment on the news and you think uh you
know as you know I I suffered a pretty
serious loss when they got rid of
stelter you see uh Zinger as an adequate
replacement to fill his tiny porcine
shoes
yeah you know I think so I will CNN
pulled their viewers it's easy there's
only 12 of them and they
it's a jury
they uh they seem to like this guy
although I to me this whole thing is
like this is a payoff in the old days
you'd bribe politicians with the
suitcase of money and now it's like you
just they funnel it through the payroll
at CNN and MSNBC and all that kind of
thing like Obama's got a 40 million
dollar deal with Netflix yeah what's
your favorite Obama produced show
that's my Obama
what is funny what's up Obama
where's Obama
I just came up with three TV shows
you should have that Netflix deal I
should I heard you got a Netflix deal I
did you know I get three DVDs a month
and
gotta return them though yes
Todd how was your holidays Splendid
Gregory thank you did you spend it with
your family I did now I'm spending
January 6th you know that holiday with
my family too
how do you celebrate January 6th with
you my friend and making fun of Adam
kinsinger crying about January 6. well I
mean he's got this he has a trademark
now of this kind of performative public
sobbing and he's gonna have to live up
to that if he stops doing that then
CNN's not going to get their money's
worth what's crazy to me about that is
he started out as a tough guy image yeah
like that was what he brought to the
table and then he regressed to like
wussy trust me as somebody who's been a
wussy his entire life if I had the
opportunity to like grab onto the tough
guy thing I wouldn't let that go I'd
hold on to that like white on rice but
the thing that is so shocking to me
you've been following the media you
studying the media CNN stated goal right
was to appeal to the pro-trump half of
the country with their new lineup
bang-up job guys you really nailed this
one this is not a republican that would
attract Republicans right this is a
republican that attracts more Democrats
more liberals more uh trumped
Arrangement syndrome so it is
interesting they've undermined their own
message so it's almost like their next
show is going to be like the Lincoln
project live or something like that you
know it doesn't make any sense but hey
they can do what they want and still fit
cat January 6th has a meaning to you
that many people don't know would you
care to share that meaning it's my dog's
birthday that's right
yeah and it was really it was really
awkward because today I was talking to
cheese the cat yeah he's like today's
such a horrible day the worst thing ever
happened today Carl was born
and I was like jeans you can't say that
people get really upset and you know
chance doesn't know when his birthday is
because he's a rescue so there's all
this conversation about privilege so
there's a lot going on in my house
wow
you asked yeah
uh uh you know it's kind of interesting
you know I know that it isn't a direct
mapping of the the whole left by stelter
and the kinsinger coming in to fill that
hole I want it to be but they they do
share that sanctimonious outrage this
Superior superiority complex that
somehow they feel more than you do are
you excited as I am well he's he's one
of those Republican butts and no not
that kind of butt so uh he's he says
everything that Democrats do but he
starts it with look I'm a republican but
yeah and then he just uses Democratic
talking points and he gets to present
himself as this Brave principled person
but really it's just another kind of
grift it's not an original thought it's
all of Democrats Thoughts with just one
little phrase tacked on to the beginning
of it exactly tired so you do you think
I'm going to be in for a big letdown
yeah yeah we were let down by that yes
yeah listen oh you know it's like I
sometimes when I when people try to be
profound you have to be profound
just because you cry doesn't give an
excuse for saying something stupid right
and he said something really stupid he
said we're not defined by bad days we're
defined by what we do during bad days
which means we're defined by bad days
[Applause]
you know my kids do it I'm like and I go
right back it doesn't change the fact
that you're still getting a spanking
this statement sucked
that's so funny
uh I'd watch a parenting show with Tyrus
wouldn't you
the debate before the whoopin is always
my favorite part because they always
bring up the record of the other kids in
the house
it's just like our government yes
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else